as soon as the truth was embodied by the
mob it was no longer a truth the truth
was in and of itself something that was
always manifested at the level of the
individual people
they know this in their own lives that
you have wisdom on your own you go into
a group and you compromise that wisdom
for some reason social norms or the way
you've dealt with past traumas or the
the things that you think other people
want to hear from you you know that's
diffusion of responsibility right
because when you're when you're buried
in the mob you can do and say things
that
the mob
hides from you in the world whereas if
you're just operating on your own that
the consequences of your actions are
manifested pretty quickly no place to
hide so
we have to keep
you know every group of people isn't a
mob either i mean there are groups of
people that are decentralized highly
functioning
aggregates hierarchies composed of
individuals and
that's working at every level of
analysis and that's a properly
functioning society that's not a mob
at that point there's a dynamic
that permeates the entire hierarchy
that keeps the individuals let's say at
the bottom of the hierarchy
completely in touch with those
smaller that smaller number of people
who are at the top and a good how
well-functioning
democratic political state has that
nature is that there's constant
communication upward and downward
just like the way the brain is organized
the brain's a hierarchy but
information doesn't just propagate from
the bottom up or from the top down even
with your visual system so for example
when information first enters your brain
from your eyes
at the foveal level each foveal that's
the center part of your vision that's
high resolution every cell in your fovea
is represented by 10 000 cells at the
first level of visual processing
and so there's a tremendous amount of
input from your eyes to your brain
bottom up
but even at the very bottom of visual
perception there's more top down
connections from your brain
so the visual system is hierarchical but
each level of the hierarchy communicates
all the way down the hierarchy and a
good political system is structured that
way and so you can have a group of
people that's not a mob
and it's a different way it's a
different organization and a democratic
a democratic polity is not a mob not if
it's functioning properly
you know it's something that was really
brought home to me when i went to
england because i went into the lobby of
the house of parliament it's this great
domed building that's more or less at
the center of the parliamentary cross
and that's where
citizens of of great britain can come
and lobby to to to speak to their
representative so that's where the voice
of the people meets the voice of the
representatives and that's how it should
work is
in some sense there are emotions and
concerns that are
stirring in an inarticulate manner at
the bottom of the
hierarchy where where the problems first
manifest themselves because they always
first manifest themselves at the bottom
of a hierarchy
those problems aren't necessarily easy
to articulate and so people stumble
forward with their concerns
and the job of their representatives is
to take those stumbling concerns and
aggregate them and to give them voice
and to transmit them up the structures
of power to transform the laws into the
new body of laws which is what we act
out to to reconcile the bottom with the
top and that has to just happen
continually because it's it's a living
it's like a living organism well it is
in a sense it is a living organism
because it's a organism that consists of
living organisms so you know for all
intents and purposes it's something
that's alive
i really it really hit me
in the lobby that's where the word
lobbying comes from by the way
so it happened there
and and people are cynical about
lobbying but
people are cynical about lots of things
and it's not that helpful what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace